[Musica]
una donna dove sono questo è strutturato
tu sei me ciao aiuto vi noi che non sono
che sono la proiezione mentale del tuo
io digitale che lo aspetta come sembra
così la proiezione mentale del tuo io
digitale sentivo avrei delle cose da
fare se mi puoi lasciare andare non puoi
vedi io ti ho liberato per una ragione
tu ci servi in pigiama
non ti preoccupare di quelli meno non è
anche un briciolo di addestramento
militare niente non so neanche sparare
non ti devi preoccupare neanche di
questo vedi in struttura
noi possiamo caricare abiti
addestramenti armi facebook
[Musica]
non corre
operatore e lo mettiamo a posto su cosa
no davvero quindi imparerò il kung fu a
camminare sui muri a schivare i
proiettili a sparare
esatto tutto questo e molto di più
wow questo sì che è un sogno che diventa
realtà
in cosa consiste il mio lavoro vedi
youtube il nostro mondo è minacciato da
entità che noi chiamiamo fim quali il
tuo compito è quello di recensirli non
ti ho sentito bene c'è interferenza una
galleria come mi hai capito me
dovrai recensire film squallidi e conti
dovrebbe censire tutti tutti
va bene se io non faccio però questa è
una truffa
non puoi opposte al tuo destino aiuto b
non dimenticarti che il cucchiaio non
esiste
[Musica]